welcome everyone I'm Kyle Evander like
the Dean of the School of Engineering
and Applied Science a few years ago the
school received an extraordinary gift to
create an endowed lectureship to
celebrate and showcase engineering in
the two ways that engineering should be
showcased and celebrated one of course
is a profession which advances the human
condition and the second is an education
which prepares students to become
leaders in a technologically driven
world this lectureship is named in
recognition of such a leader Yale
graduate Victor and Tyler from early
days working as an electrical engineer
with EG&G designing military and
communication systems the
entrepreneurial mr. Tyler went on to
found Concord computing corporation and
to pioneer the development of electronic
commerce technologies that are now
essential to the physical machinery of
our society
his vision has provided financial
institutions nationwide with ATM
processing debit card processing access
to a national debit network and deposit
risk management some members of the
Tyler family an extended family are here
today to join us including Vic's sister
Ann and her husband the Honorable Guido
Calabresi United States Circuit Judge
and former dean of the law school
sadly they could not join us this year
at the lecture as he's recuperating from
a health issue and doing well as I
understand and we wish him all the best
as he gets back on his feet and will
join us next year for the 2012 Victor
Tyler lectureship we certainly miss him
today but he won't have to miss seeing
the speaker because it is our lecture
today who has made possible the powerful
imaging technologies used in all of our
portable electronics it is with great
pleasure and with a second dose of Yale
pride that I introduce to you today the
2011 Victor Tyler lecturer dr. Eric
Fossum distinguished researcher and
scholar inventor business leader
game-changing entrepreneur Connecticut
native Eric Fossum came to Yale for his
graduate studies in engineering
receiving his PhD in 1984 working
professor with
working with professor's dick Barker and
the young and energetic TV mom who was
still young and energetic after Yale he
joined the faculty at Columbia and then
moved to Cal Tech's Jet Propulsion
Laboratory where he invented today's
camera on a chip technology for the
efficient aficionados amongst you and
you'll all be well-versed by the end of
today's lecture is this a CMOS active
pixel sensor displays in 1995 he
co-founded photo a MIT corporation to
accelerate the commercialization of the
technology and in six short years with
over a hundred employees and revenue
exceeding 20 million per year photo 'but
was acquired by micron technology dr.
Fossum then led a venture-backed startup
company simple leading it through all
the successful growth stages one can
hope for in this type of endeavor taking
it from a small R&D organization to a
thriving company that was ultimate
ultimate Lee acquired by Tessera
Technologies a publicly traded micro
electronics company that was looking to
expand into imaging and optics in
addition to serving as a consultant for
various organizations including Samsung
he has most recently returned to
academia on the faculty at Dartmouth and
the Thayer School of Engineering with
over 250 technical papers 125 patents
and numerous awards but I will point out
that Yale with its exceptional eye for
talent awarded him early in his career
with the 1984 Becton Prize his many many
other honors also include the 1996 NASA
exceptional Achievement Medal induction
into the u.s. Space Foundation
Technology Hall of Fame in 1999 and this
year he was inducted into the National
Inventors Hall of Fame we are thrilled
to have him back at Yale as our 2011
Victor M toddler lecturer please join me
in welcoming Eric Fossum
first step is to turn it on can you hear
me now
can you hear me now I didn't do anything
thank you well first of all it's a it's
a great honor and privilege to come to
Yale today to to talk about my chosen
field and it's really a pleasure to be
able to acknowledge and thank professor
MA sitting over there and dick Barker in
absentia for every graduate student
feels this way I'm sure but I felt like
it was five extraordinary years for me
at Yale and those are you at Yale now
you will look back I'm sure with great
fondness on your time here as well so
it's it's nice to be back I'm going to
talk about the science and technology of
digital imaging and I I realize that
what better place may be to talk about
some societal issues than this
particular talk so this is sort of maybe
this part of the talk the societal
issues questions or the baggage I've
been carrying around with me for a few
years and I'm going to unload on you I
hope I can unload it on you quickly and
painlessly so hey we all like to take
digital pictures this one I took out up
in Lake Winnipesaukee in New Hampshire
which is where I live these days
why don't we like to take pictures you
know I I'm not sure I think we like to
share images with other people we like
to remember things we'd like to get a
sense of what I call being there
actually we take our pictures but this
is not a new phenomenon people have been
capturing and creating
images for a long long time oops that
cave drawings from the very earliest
days that we can find Michelangelo
tormented soul this is kind of the way I
feel sometimes seems to be an
appropriate image all the way up to hey
this is okay I'm shameless this is my
cousin who is painting these days and
doing some very interesting work and
then like all good engineers that are
lazy painting is like too much work
let's find a way to just capture those
images automatically and photography was
invented actually a long time ago but
they weren't really like lasting
pictures and and probably the best-known
early camera but not the first is
daguerreotype camera which was used to
record a lot of images on glass plates
in the late 1800s the Kodak Brownie
camera was introduced where actually as
the first use of a roll of film to
capture an image and you would get the
the film maybe by mail and you would
take your pictures and you would send it
off by mail and get the pictures back so
that was a big advancement this is a SLR
camera from the 70s I had one of these
cameras at k1000 it's a fine workhorse
camera 35 millimeter film probably
everybody older than the age of 30
remembers this thing and people less
than 30 probably aren't that familiar
with film although it's strangely enough
among my daughter's a couple which are
still teenagers taking pictures with
disposable film cameras is like become a
trend again I don't know why some retro
trend but I was at the National
Inventors Hall of Fame I got to meet
Steve Stahl for the first time
and we were all dressed in our tuxedos
and feeling pretty good went over and
talked to him for a while and my
daughter comes over and says dad let me
get a picture of the two of you standing
together that's a splendid idea
and we stood there and sucked it in and
she reaches into her purse and pulls out
one of these disposable cameras to take
our picture or stephen i was like what
and walter thought that was her gag gift
to me for the night was to take our
picture on film but anyway there are
these days there are many many kinds of
digital cameras from DSLRs to
point-and-shoot cameras we don't to
think just point-and-shoot web cameras
well motion capture cameras where you
capture like an actor's facial
expressions to animate it
of course cell phone cameras are buy and
buy the the biggest use of sensor
technology today those are the most
number of cameras sold video cameras
this is a pill camera and early pill
camera this is where you'd actually
swallow this camera and it would go down
through your intestines actually the
first way to non-invasively image the
small intestine and you know a lot
better than surgery to see what's going
on inside there we built the sensor for
that that device
these are x-ray sensors for dental
camera system x-ray systems or you put
the actual sensor in your mouth and
shoot the x-rays at it and immediately
get the image which is a lot better than
trying to process film sure everybody
remembers most of you remember sitting
in a dentist's office with your face
full of cotton and something
uncomfortable going on and oh we'll just
be 10 minutes while we develop the
x-rays yeah this is much better there's
a backup camera from a car security
camera and all of these I've talked
about all used my technology now so
that's kind of fun but then one last
camera here is a 3d ranging
camera were actually measure not only
the image but the depth how far away
things are in the image and of course I
think everyone is familiar with Moore's
law that transistors get smaller and
smaller and can grow up with that the
cameras that rely on micro electronics
have also become smaller and faster and
cheaper and pretty much everywhere this
is a CCD camera which was kind of a
technology around 1993 when we invented
the CMOS image sensor technology and
it's it's a big camera by well here
present-day
here's a here's an endoscopy camera for
endoscopy that means it goes inside you
somehow and you know which one would you
rather have go inside you a or B it's
pretty remarkable achievement and cell
phone cameras even by 2007 this was a
cell phone camera module built by my
company as impel which had not only the
image sensor in the lens in it but it
also had a MEMS based actuator to move
the lens back and forth so you can do
autofocus inside this module and now
just another four or five years here's
some Sony camera modules that go inside
yourself one that's what they look like
if you were to take them out of 16
megapixels on them and autofocus so
pretty dramatic faster cheaper smaller
progression over time which gets us to
subside society discussion which I want
to put near the beginning of my talk so
I made sure there was time for it rather
than at the end when I'm rushing but you
know right now there's very ubiquitous
to have image communications and there's
all kinds of new ways that people
interact with each other so these are
just kind of well of course this is my
daughter ha who's here
and this is what it's like to live in
New Hampshire in the wintertime
and but this case this picture actually
is a geek picture so this was taken I
took this in 1999 when our very first
little camera that we built and it
wasn't in a cell phone it was still
tethered by a cord to a laptop and the
laptops weren't that small in 1999
either by the way and I took it on the
family vacation so I where I go I'd like
dragged my laptop out and then I'd have
this pic camera and I'm kind of holding
it and balancing laptop on my knee and
trying to take a picture and see what I
was getting on a laptop screen and like
a lot of strange looks so and that was
only 12 years ago compared to what we
have now so it's pretty ubiquitous but
that ubiquitousness has brought along a
lot of issues which bother me and I
think as a society we need to start
thinking about what we're gonna do about
it and the first thing that bothers me
is the fact that I feel like we can see
too much and I don't know about you but
for example during the Japanese tsunami
practically watching these pictures live
unfold I don't know about you but I felt
like helpless you know I just I I really
felt helpless being able to see this oh
yeah there's like godlike vision where
you're kind of participating in the
event and yet you're you're completely
helpless and then we also have the rapid
transmission of information and you know
for better or for worse you know it's
very easy for people to see what's going
on in other countries and in the case of
revolution spread that revolution around
like I said for better or worse I'm not
trying to make a judgment there but
that's something that wouldn't have
spread so fast in the past as it does
today by the way just a couple weeks ago
I had the pleasure of hearing build a
Vidal speak at at Dartmouth he's at
Dartmouth alum and he's a little high
tech marketing guy
and I had known him for many known of
him for many years I finally got a
chance to talk to him he was actually
talking about his book that he got
around there he was called
over-connected the promise and threat of
the internet he's mostly talking about
the fact that the internet a lot gives
us very fast feedback and really impacts
the stock market and other things things
get very violent the positive feedback
is very bad for the stability of systems
as I think any engineer knows but it
seems to me this is also part of that
phenomenon there's another set of issues
which is a loss of privacy from all this
networking when I first invented this
CMOS image sensor technology we got a
little bit of publicity and a reporter
from the BBC Radio came and talked to me
and interviewed me he said so tell me
you know how you feel about the fact
that now Big Brother is going to be able
to spy on us a lot better with all these
cameras and I said oh it's not really a
problem because there's not enough
people to watch all the video screens of
all the cameras that are out there we
don't have to worry but to my surprise
and sugar in a little bit you know now
computers can analyze images and
computer systems can track you based on
facial recognition software from camera
to camera to camera as you might move
around in a highly surveilled city for
example and so that means that you know
you can be tracked and all your activity
completely logged it's on your permanent
record now whatever you did or something
you don't want really people to know
about you know is that a good thing I
don't think so I feel like as an
invasion of my privacy and there's also
a loss of privacy from bad guys it's
probably fairly imminent that you be
able to take your cell phone camera take
a picture of a group of people and
people done this an experimental way
already but this will be commercial take
a picture of a group of people and have
something like Google search through a
facial image database and quickly on
your screen pop up tagging the names of
all the people that you might capture at
a parsing or I shot a picture here
and and if you're I mean that's kind of
nice that you know people are but if
you're a bad guy you know you can also
get all their social security
information or find out if you're
wealthy or not wealthy or they worth
kidnapping or not kidnapping or they're
away from home right now so you call
your friend and hey this guy lives at
this address and easier at the bar he's
not at home right now so that kind of
bothers me and then there's also an
admin aspect which is advertising I
don't know if any of you remember the
movie Minority Report but there was a
scene that really struck me which now
has a real potential for coming true
that characters walking through a mall
and the cameras are recognizing who he
is and immediately adapt the advertising
on the large screens to that person and
basically calling out his name and
saying hey would you like to buy a suit
today or when you look good in the new
pair of shoes or wow I this is like
really possible really soon so I don't
actually like that either I don't like
people calling me at home so I could
just go crazy in this environment and
then there's also the well-known
inappropriate use which this poster it's
unbelievable you know it's become a real
society problem there's a law in Japan
right now that cellphones have to make
al are allowed a lot of will click even
if they're turned to silent mode you
cannot turn that click off every time
the pictures taken for exactly this
reason
and then one that's also important to me
and this is talk about ethical questions
between the needs of national defense
and whether it's really right to develop
certain kinds of weapons technology but
pretty soon weapons are going to be very
very smart and very personalized hey I
just coined this so nobody else can use
this i bullets
kind of catchy don't you think but you
know laser-guided rifles or smart
bullets that are out too preloaded with
a particular person that you're out to
try to shoot out of ten people as you
fire into a crowd and to pull it would
strike the hopefully the intended person
I mean I I mean I guess it's good that
you're not striking an unintended target
but it's really not so good if you think
about it if you're at the other end of
that that event people are actively
working on is also something practically
out of Minority Report isn't it a little
spider devices to go in and infiltrate
places and do surveillance and you know
you could deliver lethal poison to
people they're sleeping with these sort
of things Nick not a good thing I'm a
big science-fiction fan as you can
probably tell by now and here's a hunter
seeker assassination device from the
movie doom eken 84 it goes out and
figures out if it's the right person to
attack or not
so this scares me also I don't don't
really like this application of my
technology and there's nothing I can do
about it I've now unloaded that on you
so thank you we'll get back to the
science and technology now but I hope
you also worry about these things and I
especially hope that you figure out what
we're gonna do about this in the future
cuz I sometimes technology moves a lot
faster than society and I'm not sure
we're ready for that okay science and
technology so back to more comfortable
topics perhaps so in a camera system we
have light that comes in light comes
from places like stars and incandescent
light bulbs and fluorescent light bulbs
the light comes in gets reflected off a
scene and it's gathered by a lens system
and the image is then focused on digital
image sensor and at the digital image
sensor the photons strike the image
sensor normas orb by a semiconductor
one thing I'll just point out on the
science side of things which is a real
nuisance from imaging is that when a
star or some other black body type
object gives off photons it's
unfortunately not like water dripping
out of a faucet a nice regular study
emission of photons it's very noisy it's
more like freeway traffic and that kind
of Statistics and it is just a nice
steady drop so as a consequence and we
try to measure the amount of light
coming from something if we make a very
short measurement and don't take a lot
of samples we get subject to a lot of
noise because it's like trying to
estimate the freeway traffic by just one
single picture at one instant of time
and trying to estimate freeway traffic
you can't really do that you have to
integrate over a larger sample before
you can feel like you're you're
statistics are meaningful so we have
that same problem with what's called
photon shot noise images and of course
of the entire electromagnetic spectrum
our eyes are really only sensitive to a
very narrow part here we call the
visible light part of the spectrum that
goes from violet through yellow and
green to red and our eyes are the most
sensitive in the green spectrum maybe
this is because we used to live in the
trees I don't know or maybe that's the
way God designed us I take your pick
photon shot noise is manifests itself
not only in time but in space if you try
to hat take a nice uniform image of what
you think should be a uniformly lit
scene and you analyze it they blow it up
and what you find and of course this is
greatly exaggerated for the purposes of
this illustration you find that even
though the light level is should be the
same that you actually statistically
measure a different number of photons in
each single pixel in your image and that
gives rise
to a nosy noisy image and it has a quite
nicely behaved characteristic as well
and if you're a photographer this shows
up and this is a simulated picture but
you take a nice picture of a nice scene
and you have a lot of noise not only do
you get this kind of speckling going on
but you can even get the color to shift
on you and you know that's just not good
if you're trying to sell cameras your
camera does this sort of thing another
thing besides photon shot noise on the
science side of things is the
diffraction limit and the diffraction
limit says that hey if I take a a
perfect point source like a star a
zillion miles away and I put it through
a perfect lens I'm still going to wind
up with this diffraction pattern of
light no matter what I do pretty much
and the width of this airy disc by
mister airy the width of this disc
depends on the wavelength of light and
also the f-number of the optical system
and if I pick like F 2.8 optics common
on cell phone camera perhaps and I look
at the green light I see that the size
of this disc the diameter is about four
microns which seems pretty small four
microns is really small but as you'll
see we're already making pixels that are
smaller than that so that brings up an
interesting question nowadays light go
through the main lens but when it goes
into the semiconductor we usually we
have to put wires and other things on
top of the chip and so not all the light
can get into the active part if it's
blocked by these wires so we actually
put micro lenses on the top surface
there's some actual micro
I kind of funneled the like that's not
an imaging lens but it funnels a light
instead of going down and hitting the
metal wire it funnels it into the active
part of the detector and as you saw in
that lesson we also need filters because
we want to measure how much light is
green and how much is red and how much
is blue and it's hard very very
difficult to do that with low noise all
at the same point in space so we cheat a
little bit we sorry have remote control
ideas here we we actually cover one
pixel with let's say a green filter and
one with a red filter and one with a
blue filter and repeat that pattern this
is the so-called error pattern this
acted this particular pattern across the
imaging array and so at any one point
we're not actually measuring all the
colors we're just measuring one color
we'll get back to how we fix that soon
so once we have the light down into the
pixel we have some semiconductor device
physics that come into play and this is
basically what happens inside a
semiconductor and a pass semiconductor
that we found so far is silicon and in
silicon it's you may remember from
chemistry it's covalently bonded I mean
it's it's like a diamond it really is
like diamond and the way carbon bonds so
this is really strong and and of course
replicates across the crystal if we put
an electric field that's this arrow here
with an e on it and a photon comes in
the photon if it has enough energy it
can actually break one of these bonds
and when it breaks the bond it the
electron that was participating in that
bond is released and it starts to drift
away in the silicon there's an electron
drifting away and not only does it drift
away but where it used to be leaves
behind a hole kind of like a bubble in
water and
you all know that bubbles go against
gravity in fact if you ever look at that
they're looking at your beer sometime
and you look at the bubbles you feel
like you're looking at the bubbles
they're real things actually bubbles
aren't real things right that's the it's
actually the beer that's moving down it
just looks like the bubbles moving up
well now you know I spent my time at
Yale I guess but uh anyway that's what
happens I we call that the hole and both
the electron and the hole participate in
the conduction process now the energy of
the photon if it's high enough energy
then the probability that it breaks one
of these bonds is really high so if you
look at blue light which is higher
energy as you go down and distance into
the semiconductor it gets absorbed very
quickly where is a lower energy photons
like green or even red they can absorb
much more slowly and they can penetrate
much more deeper into the silicon and
this is the this is the advanced slide
so don't worry about this unless the six
of you that are in the audience that
know about this I'll just mention that
this is the structure that we we build
which is a varied PN Junction are
something called pin photodiode and so
we separate the electron hole pair and
the electrons are gathered in a
potential well due to this band bending
here in the N region and the hole is
free to wander elsewhere and so what
happens we shine light on this device
for some time and it generates lots of
electrons that are gathered in this well
and at the end we try to measure how
much how many electrons we've gathered
it's kind of like trying to measure rain
by seeing how much water you collect in
a bucket out on a football field except
that in the case of an image sensor
we've got thousands or millions of
buckets across the football field each
one is measuring the rain that's falling
in there and and when we get done with
some time you know a thirtieth of a
second or in the case of rain I don't
always an hour or something goes by you
want to see how much has been collected
in each bucket we have to somehow read
out the signal in each of those buckets
so oh yeah one other thing by the way we
keep talking with the light coming in
from the front of the chip I just
mentioned that it's quite possible and
done these days that here's the top of
the chip with all the wiring and we were
worried about using a micro lens to
thread the light through these wires but
another way to do this even though it's
more expensive is to actually fit in the
crystal down from the back side and put
the filters on the back underside of the
chip and have the light come in from the
backside so it doesn't have to get past
all those wires and that's called
backside illumination you'll see cameras
out there now that advertise using
backside illumination like Sony's Exmor
R series of chips so now we have to read
out all those buckets of rain or buckets
of signal and the way we sorry the way
we do that in the old days is with a CCD
which is a shift register we actually
just move the charge electrostatically
from place to place to place the place
and finally all the way out to the
corner of the chip where it goes out
through an amplifier and this idea of
moving charge through a semiconductor in
this way was actually the subject of the
2009 Nobel Prize which was given a
Willard Boyle and and also Smith
unfortunately Boyle just passed away
recently but not so long ago the Nobel
Prize was awarded now ok so shifting the
charge out is is not so good in fact let
me make the comment that while you're
trying to shift the charge out here if
you have any defect in the silicon it
will block the transfer of charge
through it just like someone was
blocking it not not a good thing in fact
if this kind of device goes up in space
and there's some energetic particle that
comes in and breaks the silicon toward a
make creates a defect in the silicon it
will also wreck the image sensor and my
job when I went to JPL was the chief
scientist at that time at JPL asked me
to
help them with this problem of
reliability of CCDs in a space
environment you know how do we how do we
fix that problem and that's where I
started working on this active pixel
idea and in the active pixel oh of
course we have the charge it's generated
in each each pixel and we are going to
also integrate an amplifier inside the
pixel each pixel and the always I could
do that is because of Moore's law that
we could actually make things that small
at that time so timing is pretty
important and by basically this little
circuit here the voltage that goes into
this amplifier decreases over time as
more and more light is absorbed in the
semiconductor and at the end of this
time which may be a thirtieth of a
second for video we read out that
voltage and that tells us what the light
intensity was at that particular spot so
that's organized by having all these
pixels and amplifiers and a bunch of
switches and then some some analog
signal processing and and as it turns
out because we don't have to transfer
this charge a lot of steps we can use
just mainstream micro electronics
technology CMOS technology to make this
chip and if we use mainstream micro
electronics technology that means that
not only can we build this device but we
can add all kinds of other electronics
to the same chip because they all get
made at the same time that's the magic
of micro electronics and why it's so
cheap these days to buy computers so in
our case not only do we integrate this
this readout but we can put the a 10 D
converter or we can put timing control
logic and all kinds of other things on
the chip for basically making a camera
on a chip so we have all this other
stuff on there and now we have a chip
where you can just like basically put in
power and out comes an image so that
that paved the way for building real
miniature cameras and gave rise to all
those problems which I didn't foresee
back then sad to say the integration
these days on cameras on a chip is quite
extensive we'll talk about color
interpolation a little bit but there's
all kinds of things that have to happen
on ship like flicker detection you know
these lights up here are actually
flickering on and off at high frequency
and if you try to take a picture and
it's not synchronized the way the lights
are flickering you know part of the
image might be exposed and part of it
not exposed so well depending upon the
shutter it gets complicated but it looks
ugly believing so you have to figure out
exactly how the lights are flickering so
that you can avoid that effect just as
one example color interpolation I told
you that we kind of cheat we only put
red green or blue filter over each pixel
but it only takes you a minute to think
about how we might fix that later and
that is let's let's say we're got this
pixel right here and we we know what the
red is exactly but we don't know what
the green or the blue is and so what do
you do well you just say okay I can just
average them the four greens around me
and I'll call that the green value at
this point and all interpolate from the
four blues and call that the blue at
that point and I'm done I only have a
red green and blue value the only
problem that with that particular
algorithm as simple as it sounds is that
the the red sample is from a point and
the green sample is averaged over this
neighborhood and the blue sample is
averaged over that neighborhood and
that's kind of asymmetric and we really
don't like some artifacts that that that
yields in our final image so the actual
algorithms people use for color
tribulations are much more sophisticated
than that that gives you some idea hey
not only does the camera have to do all
this stuff but there's more to the story
because when you take a picture and then
you look at it on the screen
you expect that what you see looks as
good as what it looked like when you
took the picture if not a little
special thin you out feature or
something who knows enhance the color
give you a little better skin tone or
something like that so
and there's also justice there's also
the step of having the display has got
its own characteristics not only do we
take the pictures through silicon that's
got color filter array characteristics
and silicon absorption characteristics
never go through display it's got its
own on spectrum of light that it puts
out in different ratios and and the
green that the display is covered with
red green and blue filters and it may
not be exactly the same filters that are
in your camera and you want to try to
make those match and it's it's quite a
job so the light out part is is also a
big step so that brings us to the state
of the art the state of the art for
sensors for consumers are in 8 to 16
megapixel range now pixel counts for
professional cameras and we have 20 to
40 megapixels 100 megapixels for
aerospace and pixel sizes or maybe down
to 2.2 to 1.1 microns for common
consumer applications well if you've
been following the thread here I
mentioned to you that the diffraction
limit says that hey you know the best we
can focus a spot - and that's only the
center spot it's 4 microns and yet we've
got pixels that are 1.1 microns what
does that mean well it it means my
favorite saying almost my favorite
saying which is the force of marketing
is greater than the force of engineering
if the number on the box is bigger it
will sell so hey nobody ever really
checks the resolution anyway we'll put
more pixels on and maybe someday someone
to figure out and software how to make
the images better
unfortunately it's physics that's
working against you so it's not so easy
to fix but hey pays the bills so for us
engineers and gives us something to do
the and before long you know it took a
long time to go from television
resolution which is point three
megapixels to HDTV resolution which is
about two megapixels but the next
generation is super hi-vision or UD TV
which is 33 megapixels at least 60
frames per second maybe 120 frames per
second this is a really high data rate
and for a long time most of us thought
that will not happen in our lifetime
because it took so long just to get the
television broadcasting infrastructure
to go from TV to HDTV that going to 33
will never happen but now that video is
delivered by network in packet form and
a bunch of other things that we really
never anticipated it doesn't have to get
broadcast across the air anymore
maybe adoption rate for a uni TV or
super hi-vision imaging would be a lot
faster than we anticipated earlier so
maybe I'll get to see that I actually
saw a uni TV camera actually built the
first chip for the first dd TV camera at
in Japan a number of years ago and they
had a they also had to develop a display
technology and they had this big movie
screen and you think that going to the
movies regularly you think you know what
the resolution is but when you see
something that's at this resolution
it really is lifelike you don't realize
how much you're missing in a normal
projected image until you see a UD TV
image projected it's like wow look at
those trees at the back of the field I
can see the branches on those trees just
like you can in real life so that
sensation of being there of realism is
really much more pronounced when you go
to super high resolution than
normal TV so should be interesting ahead
to have a wall-sized display in your
house to watch video on that's at that
really realistic resolution should be
pretty interesting especially if it's in
3d so coming attractions well first
coming attraction is more camera phones
so this is a trend from Sony everybody
has their own numbers but this is what
Sony thinks the market has been and will
look like so pick us out here in 2011
they're saying it's about 1.25 billion
cell phone cameras camera phones will be
manufactured and sold in 2011 so that
works out I forget what it is but it's
probably like on the order of one per
second that's manufactured which is
pretty astounding if you think about it
a camera a second it's also equally
astounding if you think about that's one
cell phone per second going into
landfill three years from now or two
years from now kind of scary in just a
few years that number is going to climb
up even more so it's a remarkable growth
and then this also shows that the
resolution is going to go from maybe 8
megapixels and those camera phones to
probably a lot of they'll have 12 mega
phones 12 megapixels in just just a few
years a trend in pixels also as you can
guess is getting smaller and smaller and
FSI means the front side illumination
and BSI is the back side illumination we
were talking about and this is pixel
size going from 4 microns hey by the way
this is the diffraction limit for green
light on F 2.8 down to one micron or 0.9
microns coming up so these really small
pixels are coming and in product to you
soon so why do a lot smaller pixels well
smaller pixels allow smaller chips
reduces the chip cost the camera module
maker if you can make a smaller chip
that cost less because the highway furs
not individual chips if you can make
more chips per wafer you're
shape a smaller chip means that the
optic size is also reduced and that cost
comes down and smaller camera modules
then are more desirable for integration
into consumer products you know now you
see a lot of cameras that are embedded
into your display screen to the top at
the little bezel or you want it your
very thin iPad you want a camera built
in there you know it's got to be really
small up is really small you can put it
practically anywhere so that's that's
good from consumer point of view
unfortunately the negative sizing is
that the non-recurring engineering cost
of the chip is higher so that tends to
slow things down and the performance of
the pixels usually degraded because when
they're smaller they collect less light
basically go through all these reasons
or you can either reduce the size of the
chip or you can put more pixels per chip
is as a flipside of that so that's good
and more megapixels cells more cellular
service traffic because you have higher
data rates or larger data files you need
bigger computers better software mass
storage requirements go way up
so hey everybody's on board this train
ok this is a good thing so push push
push for more pixels hey we can't see
the image any better because of the
diffraction limit but the bigger number
on the box helps lead to all these other
benefits as well and that's just the
name of the game okay so on to sub
diffraction limit pixels this is just a
graphic on a point 9 micron pixel pitch
and there is that 4 micron diffraction
limit we see that the hey there's a lot
of pixels inside that blur spot so that
it really is some real limit at how
small it's practical according to the
way we make sensors now another thing
that's coming you know in the future is
higher dynamic range so we can take
pictures that have you know you take a
picture inside a room and you have a
bright scene outside the window and
you'd like to get both things show up in
the image at the same time you know
that's practically impossible right now
that's just because of the range of
light that a single image can capture we
want to improve that higher speed
readout it's not only good
for slow motion but it's good for blur
reduction and I see this already in
recent camera that I bought and in your
low-light I go to take a picture and it
actually takes like four pictures or six
pictures and the reason is of course my
hand is shaking as I'm taking trying to
hold steady on this low light long
shutter time image and so it divides it
up into like four separate exposures
that are shorter and idea is that the
amount of shaking that goes on during
each short exposure time is small and
then I take those four separate pictures
and I use software to register them back
together again and get rid of the blur
now I can only do that if I have a very
high-speed readout it's pretty clever
yeah so okay now there's also research
activity that is may change the paradigm
and I'm going to talk more about the
quantitative sensor because that's my
own favorite thing and the 3d imaging
I'll also talk about in a moment we're
almost near the end of this talk but I
do want to mention that computational
imaging may be important this is where
we do certain functions like this
getting rid of blur by adding images
together or even more clever things by
using the increase in computation that's
also come along in the course of Moore's
law so now we can compute a lot of
things that we couldn't before so you
could maybe take an image that's out of
focus and mathematically restore it to a
perfect focus for example another
example that is a plant optic sensor
which may or may not pan out
commercially but that's the sensor we
actually have a lot of little lenses on
the chip with a number of pixels under
each lens and every each lens is aligned
a little bit differently to the pixels
underneath that sees a different part of
the image kind of spider eye maybe or
fly eye kind of thing and then we use
computation to put all those images back
together and make one nice image we'll
see if that goes anywhere okay so let me
so this is my research so now notice I
put the societal issues first and I know
that I'm gonna get jammed on the time
for my own research but that's okay
if you if you want to go really small I
want to consider a very specialized tiny
pixel which I term a jot that comes from
the Greek for a smallest thing that's
sensitive to a single electron and the
jot state the jot state changes from
zero to one kind of in a binary way when
a foot electron is present in order to
sense that we need some special single
electron amplifier or single electron
transistor which is small and compact
and we're gonna want billions on a
single chip so that jawed itself has to
be really small maybe 0.12 0.5 micron
pitch so that's ten times ten smaller
area than what we're seeing in the stay
there's a 100 times smaller area and the
state-of-the-art and billions on a
single chip is also hundreds of times
more dots or pixels on the chip than the
current state of the art and if we do
that we could build a Giga jot sensor
and it would only be about a quarter
inch in diagonal so that's kind of
interesting the astronomers now are
putting together a gigapixel telescope
camera and that chip actually you can't
put a billion pixels on a single chip
right now so they actually have like
hundreds of chips all carefully mounted
and calibrated on this giant platform to
get up to a billion pixels so maybe in
the future we can put a billion pixels
just in your cell phone camera and also
a interesting thing about this is a
change in the paradigm because right now
we have this bucket that's not on the
football field that's collecting rain
and here's the here the raindrops that
come in and hit in the bucket and in the
end we read out the value of that signal
and we decide that that corresponds to
the gray it's not black it's not white
it's somewhere between it's gray but if
we actually count every single photon
that hits the image plane and not only
that we read it out very quickly at very
high speed so that we only get kind of
sparse
sparse illumination on every single
subframe we can take a lot of sub frames
over some area and do some sort of
nonlinear 3d convolution both in space
and time and to generate some image
pixel value so rather than being
confined by the physical boundaries of
the silicon pixel now we're really not
confined our pixel is now kind of a
software kind of construct so we've
really moved the whole idea of image
formation so that it's it's very digital
and we're kind of preserving the digital
nature of those photons that come in and
light so here's what it looks like the
most important thing on here besides the
fact that there's billions and billions
of these jots and we have to read them
out at high speed it means the data that
comes out of this chip if you calculate
it out for a normal illumination is
somewhere around 10 terabytes per second
so you know we can figure out how to do
maybe 10 gigabits maybe 100 gigabits per
second read off off chip that's
state-of-the-art so somewhere in the
next hopefully years we're going to
figure out how to do this I don't know
how we're doing it but I know we're
gonna do it so we had a discussion
earlier about do you have faith in what
your technology is and I am just 100%
sure that we will solve this problem I
just don't know how it's going to happen
quite yet the second and last thing I
want to talk about is just sensing not
only the normal image but sentencing the
distance to objects and I think you all
have an intuitive idea about how sonar
works this is not so different in this
case well if we just send out a single
pulse of light from this LED and it
bounced off an object and came back into
the camera it's easy to just write down
the speed of light and the distance and
calculate with the elapsed time is or if
we measure the elapsed time we give them
work backwards and get the distance to
the object unfortunately it doesn't get
very good signal-to-noise ratio so
gonna set out a series of pulses of
light that bounce back and go to a
particular pixel and a light that also
bounces off some other place in the
scene and hits a different pixel and
notice that because the distance to the
object is different in these two things
and also because I'm good at cartoons
the there's a phase difference between
these two pulses that come back and so
if we draw the LED pulse and the return
pulse we can see that the phase
difference is due because of the
difference in distance to the object so
if we can measure the phase difference
of these pulses we can also get range
and so we just have to do that for all
the pixels in a sensor to get the result
this is not a new idea this has been
around for quite a while it's one of the
projects I'm working on Oh a samsung
we're trying to catch up to a lot of
people and I don't reason I'm talking
about it now is because we've caught up
and actually going past other people now
sorts it's worth talking about so this
is a device that okay I invented but
it's a special kind of device sensor
device it's a lock in pixel and we built
an array of okay not too many but we can
actually this is a collected decent
range image this is a picture of
somebody standing there with their hands
up and it's a color coded according to
distance so that this brighter light
green means it's closer to the camera
and this means this color means it's
farther away from the camera this
actually goes from 1 meter to 7 meters
on this color scale back here and if you
look at the extracted distance versus
the real distance you see we get a very
nice linear result and the distance
error is well under 1% over that
distance range now it's an odd pose you
might think for somebody to take a
picture of Boop stop but not really the
reason is is that this type of range
sensor is very good for gesture control
so Kinect is already out in the market
you know you kind of do things with
their hands or and it controls the game
I'm gonna think that a lot more steps
further and the first thing you have to
be able to really do to do good gesture
control is be able to see individual
fingers and that is the point of this
particular pose is that we can actually
discriminate all the fingers on the hand
and then there's a fingers move we can
see that difference distance and again
like some science fiction movie we can
control computer screens or movies or no
don't need the remote controlled your TV
anymore all kinds of applications good
and bad I'm sure I have a thought yet
but it's probably coming soon one step
beyond that where we are now so this is
state of the art the fact this doesn't
even get announced until February so
you're getting a preview we're
interested in this vision where you can
take a picture with your cell phone
camera of something and okay so I do
work part time for Samsung there's my
consulting activity and it's what a
Samsung build right now they build 3d
TVs well that's just lovely
that's like building HGTV before their
HDTV broadcasts were out it's like there
just isn't a whole lot of 3d media
content out there we have to enable
people to be able to make 3d content
before can sell a lot of 3d TVs right so
it's a big push to ever since the movie
Avatar came out frankly to to be able to
generate to allow consumers to generate
3d images and so in this case we've
taken a 2 megapixel color sensor and
every now and then we've inserted a time
of flight range sensor inside and of
course the color sensor we know works
works fine and this image shows the
color coded rain sensor over much higher
resolution now you can actually see
what's here's a lab there's a whiteboard
computer terminal and some other stuff
in the background and it's all coded as
far as distance
distance from the camera and you also
see the speckle and hopefully now that
we're at the conclusion of this talk you
have some inkling of where all that
speckle noise is coming from in this
image it means that we don't have very
good signal-to-noise ratio and we're
seeing a lot of shot noise so with that
I would like to conclude with a couple
of comments first okay I've listened to
a lot of rock and roll in my life so
life's been good to me so far so you
know that song I'm sure image centers
have come a long way since the first
generation devices CCD a second
generation devices CMOS active pixel
sensor is going strong billions and
billions sir I'm very susceptible to
advertising I guess much interesting
work I believe lies ahead as we move the
digital divide as close as possible to
the digital nature of photons and in a
to build a Bedell I think this over
connection of billions of massive
information gathering engines I mean
think about how much information a
camera gathers and there's billions made
per year out there is going to lead to
some very interesting societal issues
and questions thank you very much for
inviting me
yes so which advanced the and you go
well I think that when I call my dark
anxiety closet
I open the door so all those things just
get worse I think and you know it's it's
really hard as an engineer not to go
forward and you know it's Oh guns don't
kill people people kill people I don't
know about that argument but it's a good
rationalization sometimes and I don't
know what the story is on this
technology I hope it's used to good I
know it's not going to be always used to
the best tonight yes I have lots of
anxieties and I think I shared them with
you already
yeah so the question is can I say
something about moving and I guess you
mean me versus technology or so me
personally academic life versus yeah I
you know it's not it's not that
different I think that a big part of
academic life is nurturing people and
their skills and moving them along and
ahead and if you're a good manager in a
research lab or any corporation that is
one of the things you focus on is
helping move people forward and up in
the process of accomplishing your goals
as a as a professor you develop a lot of
communication skills maybe I didn't
exhibit them all but there you need
strong communication skills and you may
be able to communicate your ideas or
vision to sponsors for research you need
to be able to communicate those ideas to
students and in industry it's the same
thing if you are trying to raise money
you're still trying to communicate your
vision to people with money and get them
to part with their money and give it to
you to accomplish you have to you have
to give them the spirit right you need
to really evangelize fantasize your your
vision and and well I'd say that part is
the same that's probably the hardest
part of any job is and it's always it's
been the same for me from being a
university professor and trying to get
money to being in a government lab which
guess what you still have to get money
from other parts of the government to
being in private industry where you have
to go get money well you feel like the
same job to me so it's it's not that big
of a transition but I have to say of all
these things really developing people
and relationships with people and
watching them grow beyond what I've
taught them has been really the most
rewarding part of my career so far
when what stage in your life okay so the
question is what stage of my career did
I start coming up with things and what
was my reaction to doing that and I have
to say that I had the good fortune of
participating in a science program at in
Connecticut at the top at Mountain
Science Center up in Avon Connecticut
which was a kind of a supplementary high
school program on Saturdays and there
were a lot of very bright people that
were in that program from the state
basically around the state and I always
felt like a slacker because they were
always come up with these great ideas
about what to look at and I was like I
can't come with any good ideas I was
really discouraged and college you know
I was like okay I could solve problems I
could do things and and you know I
started having my own ideas and what I
thought when I had that it was well
certainly someone's already thought of
this and there's something I'm not
seeing as to why this idea hasn't
already like made it big time yet and
I'm just too dumb to figure out what
that problem is and can't possibly be
true that I came up with something new
and there's so there's a self-confidence
issue that kind of comes up when you
come up with something new to really
believe that it's new and it's hard to
overcome and it's over years and now I
feel like wow I got ideas all the time
now and something I still feel I just
had an idea the other day for the
details of what it was but I talked to
one of my colleagues is another feel
that said surely this exists already
he's like no I don't think so
I'm like really maybe it doesn't on the
other hand I started a company a year
and a half ago
based on an idea which I thought was a
great idea and I searched the web I
didn't see any
and dragged in a partner and we worked
on a prototype thing and just before
about to file a bunch of patents which
meant spending a lot of money I did one
last Google search and I must have typed
in a couple different keywords and right
there in front of me was some master
thesis from Carnegie Mellon from like 12
years ago it was exactly exactly what I
wanted to work on out there in the
public domain and the whole IP core that
we're gonna build this company and I
just went poof
and guess what sometimes those ideas are
already been had even if you can't find
them at first well I actually I in
earlier versions of this talk I talked
about maybe applying neural networks to
processing this data but I think the
fundamental difference is and maybe it's
not a blocking factor but silicon
technology is a planar technology and
biological barone neurons and are is a
3d topology and I think that makes a big
difference because you can only get the
data out in a planar form lots of wires
coming out but it's kind of still kind
of planar in topological sense and so I
think the interconnectivity is is
limited and I don't know if you could
just read it out fast enough and then
have a faster processor that REM you
lates that 3d connectivity or not I
think it's an interesting open question
but we're not quite ready to attack it
but yeah very good observation thought
about that several times
let me just comment things by way of
conclusion that on this day when we
celebrate engineering it could not be a
more fitting celebration in the sense
that engineering really is the bridge
between the sciences and the humanities
do that without considering all the
consequences and implications a small
token they're gonna give everybody the
car we'd like to offer you a chance to
take a picture appreciation
Wow that's a big place for them for that
beer bubble invite everybody to a
reception right outside where you can
thank you thank you